[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes de débat de
chronique et de reportage comme tous les
soirs du lundi au jeudi 18h et 22h sur
Public Sénat notre objectif c'est de
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
invités experts Gabriel Atal s'attaque
au tabou du redoublement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a annoncé une
série de mesures pour mettre fin à la
baisse de niveau des collégiens français
une lente dérive dénoncée par les
parlementaires sommes-nous condamnés à
observer cette land de chute à chaque
livraison PISA et comment pouvons-nous
principalement au collège à inverser la
donne comment assurer aux françaises et
aux Français que nous serons désormais
en mesure de regagner notre
rang redoublement groupe de niveau
brevet obligatoire pour passer en
seconde la la potion àale sera-t-elle
magique comment les enseignants vont-ils
la digérer on en débat dans une minute
et puis pour notre second thème
direction l'Argentine où le nouveau
président doit prêter serment
dimanche c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire que nous allons avoir un
président qui est un
économiste orthodoxe jusqu'au bout des
ongles et celui qui viendra dépenser je
lui couperai la
main ravier m candidat d'extrême droite
économiste ultra libéral fait figure de
nouvel épouvantail mais pour comprendre
son succès il faut analyser des
décennies de peréronisme de corruption
de crise économique comment les
Argentins sont-ils tombés dans les bras
d'un candidat qui a fait campagne
tronçonneuse à la main réponse dans tris
quart d'heure mais d'abord cette
nouvelle enquête PISA dévoilée ce matin
et le détail des mesure annoncé par le
ministre hatal avec Fabien
RER face au décrochage des élèves
français et en particulier des
collégiens Gabriel Atal appelle à sortir
du dénis et promet un électrochoc je me
sens un devoir de vérité vis-à-vis des
Français notamment ce qui concerne le
niveau de nos élèves il y a là une vraie
urgence nationale le ministre présente
un paquet de mesures pour rendre le
collège plus exigeant dès la rentrée
2024 la décision du redoublement
n'appartiendra plus aux parents d'élèves
mais au seuls professeurs Gabriel hatal
promet un brevet des collèges plus
difficiles véritable examen d'entrée
pour accéder au lycée ainsi que des
groupes de niveau en 6e et en 5e pour le
français et les Matth dans chaque
collège du pays les élèves de chaque
classe seront répartis en trois groupes
en fonction de leur niveau en français
et en mathématiques pour mener à bien ce
chantier évidemment nous accompagnerons
encore davantage les professeurs les
élèves les plus en difficulté auront
droit à un parcours individualisé ainsi
que des stages de réussite selon Gabriel
hatal plusieurs milliers d'enseignants
seront recrutés pour assumer ses
missions des mesures pour répondre à une
chute historique du niveau des élèves
français pointé par l'étude PISA 2022 de
l'OCDE qui compare les performances
scolaires dans 81 pays si la France se
situe toujours dans la moyenne elle
favorise plus que d'autres la
reproduction des inégalités sociales à
l'école la grande faiblesse du système
d'éducation français c'est son problème
le déterminisme social le fait de venir
d'un milieu des favorisé qui n'est pas
compensé par le système éducatif afin de
lutter contre cette fracture scolaire
les experts de l'OCDE Appell notamment à
rendre le métier d'enseignant plus
attractif et les mesures annoncées par
Gabriel Atal sont-elles efficaces pour
rehausser le niveau des collégiens
français on en débat avec Guilen David
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes ccrétaire
général porte-parole du syndicat snip
FSU Sophie coagard bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste éitorialiste
politique au point auteur de ce livreir
la tyrannie de la médiocrité médiocrité
publié aux éditions de l'Observatoire
j'accueille Cédric Vial bonsoir
bienvenue sénateur rattachéir de la
Savoie et membre de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication et laéticia crupa
éitoraliste politique bonsoir Letia je
commencer on a beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder mais par l'une des mesures
annoncé par Gabriel Atal celle qui
concerne les groupes de niveaux
instaurer des groupes de niveau en
français et en math au collège Guen
David est-ce que vous approuvez non on
approuve pas parce que que on sait aussi
que de ce point de vue-là un peu comme
le redoublement la recherche
scientifique c'est beaucoup intéressé à
ces groupes de niveau à tester ce genre
de choses et on sait que ça ne favorise
pas notamment pour les élèves les plus
faibles une réussite scolaire on sait
que ça ça va ségréguer et ça ne va pas
permettre aux élèves les plus faibles de
d'avoir ces connaissances et ses
compétences il vaut mieux toujours avoir
de l'hétérogénéité dans la classe et de
la mixité pour pouvoir justement voir
apprendre ensemble entre pè c'est
beaucoup plus efficace et notamment
aussi pour les élèves qui se
débrouillent le mieux hein qui ont un
meilleur niveau parce que ils sont en
aide et en coopération donc tous les
experts scientifiques et enfin les
scientifiques de enfin les les
rechercheurs en science de l'éducation
le disent l'ont d'ailleurs dit beaucoup
ces derniers temps il le dit d'ailleurs
gabrielal dans son discours il dit je
sais que c'est pas approuvé par tout le
monde mais je je tente les choses et
puis en la question de l'estime de soi
c'est-à-dire que les élèves qui sont
très en difficulté que l'on va mettre
tous ensemble ça ça ça montre vraiment
que il y a les bons il y a les les les
forts et et qu'on on fait pas partie
desffs quand on est dans le groupe de
niveau des f ça existe déjà d'une
certaine manière puisqu'il y a des
groupes de soutien qui sont pour les
élèves en difficulté et donc ils
quittent leurs camarades de la pause il
y a la différence entre les groupes de
niveau et les groupes de besoins
c'est-à-dire que faire un groupe de
besoin à un moment donné dans une classe
au sein de la classe on va prendre un
petit groupe et on va travailler avec ce
petit groupe par contre les sortir et
les identifier à ce moment-là c'est
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau enfin c'est
pas en tout cas c'est pas souhaité pour
pour nous c'est pas settable pour les
éles pas sûr que tout le monde a la même
analyse sur les groupes de niveau il a
dit Gabriel Atal s'inspirer de ce qui
existe dans d'autres pays européens la
Suède la Suisse ou ou le Danemark Sophie
coager votre avis est-ce que ça pourrait
s'importer en France est-ce que vous y
êtes favorable vous à ces groupes de
niveau je trouve que ça vaut le coup
d'être tenté en tout cas au point où on
en est si jeose dire euh moi je suis
toujours un peu perplexe quand je lis
euh les différentes euh comment
dirais-je les différentes critiques qui
ont plus avant même euh les annonces de
Gabriel atthal des chercheurs en science
de l'éducation alors ces gens-là sont
sûrement extraordinairement savants mais
en fait ils accompagnent il y en a qui
disent depuis 30 ans on le sait que
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire mais
alors depuis 30 ans on applique quand
même vraisemblablement leur
préconisation et on peut pas dire que ce
soit une réussite éblouissante donc il y
a un moment où l'idée de faire j'allais
dire dans le pragmatisme voir le bon
sens qui est pas forcément toujours une
bonne chose mais essayons c'est pas
comme si toutes ces choses apportées par
tous ces experts en sciences de
l'éducation nous avaient amené à
l'excellence pour tous Cédric votre avis
oui moi je suis plutôt favorable après
je pense qu'il faut pas faut pas
considérer que c'est la panassée non non
il y a plein d'autres mesures on va y a
plein d'utres mur mais mais
effectivement je je pense
que on souffre du pas de Stig comme on a
souffert du pas de vague VO et et que ce
discours qui est de dire il faut surtout
pas que les les élèves se sentent
différents des autres qui se sentent
moins bon ou meilleur ce qui a conduit à
la suppression des notes qui à mon avis
est une erreur parce qu'on peut pas
corriger quand on n pas évalué qui qui
qui revient aussi à ce DISP enfin à ce
dispositif de dire il vaut mieux que
tout le monde soit au même niveau et
surtout ceux qui seraient moins bons
doivent pas se rendre compte qu'ils sont
moins bons que les autres non je je je
pense au contraire qu'on doit pouvoir
donner aussi des perspectives aux élèves
ceux qui sont moins bons doit pouvoir
les aider à à progresser et donc mettre
des moyens supplémentaires pour les
aider à progresser et leur donner la
perspective même de changer de groupe
c'est c'est ça doit être une motivation
aussi et et si on ne s'occupe pas des
élèves ben ils y arriveront moins bien
donc je pense que s'en occuper de cette
manière-là nous ça fait partie en tous
les cas dans dans ma famille politique
entre guillemets dans le courant de
pensée que qu'on représente même si on
peut avoir des avis plus ou moins
différents sur certains points des
proposition qu'on qu'on qu'on met sur la
table depuis un certain nombre d'années
déjà alors je vais vousedonner la parole
sur ce thème parce que je suis sûr que
vous avez plein d'arguments pour contrer
ce qui vient d'être dit mais mais vous
avez parlé de stigmatisation évidemment
le le le ministre il a anticipé cette
critique voilà ce qu'il répondait à à à
l'accusation entre guillemets de
stigmatiser les élèves avec ses groupes
de niveau un élève qui est encore une
fois systématiquement dans sa classe en
échec scolaire avec la difficulté à
comprendre ce qui se passe dans sa
classe est-ce que quelque part il est
pas stigmatisé en général ce que vous
disent beaucoup c'est qu'il il os même
plus poser poser de questions à
l'enseignant dans la classe préc
précisément parce qu'il se sent
stigmatisé parce qu'il a beaucoup de
retard et de lacune par rapport à ses
camarades Guilen David je voudrais juste
comprendre puis ça vous permettre de
répondre aussi à à ce que vient de dire
Gabriel àal mais on on dis groupe de
besoin de groupe de niveau c'est quoi
c'est de la sémantique une vraie
différence j'ai un peu l'impression
qu'on joue sur les mots moi c'est pas de
la sémantique c'est-à-dire que à un
moment donné et d'ailleurs ça pour le
coup depuis
2008 on met en place de du soutien aux
élèves en difficulté d'accord de l'APC
des activités pédagogiques
complémentaires on sort les élèves de la
classe on met en place stag c'est ce
qu'il veut faire mais ça ne fonctionne
pas et c'est pourtant ce qu'il veut
faire il réutilise les bonnes vieilles
méthodes il veut remettre en place ça on
sait que ça ne fonctionne pas par contre
on a eu pendant toute une période à
l'école primaire j'entends je parle de
l'école primaire puisque je suis
enseignante professeur des écoles à
l'école primaire on a eu ce qu'on a
appelé le plus de mtres que de classe un
enseignant sur numéraire dans une école
qui peut dans chaque classe pr prendre
un petit groupe en même temps que
l'enseignant est là dissocier les
groupes faire de la la co de la
cointervention entre les les enseignants
avoir un double regard parce que vous
savez nous les professeurs des écoles on
est très seul dans notre classe face à
la difficulté scolaire on n pas double
regard on a besoin d'avoir un enseignant
en face qui nous disent bah oui mais là
il fonctionne pas très bien parce que
peut-être que c'est cette difficulté
qu'il a pas et qu'on puisse discuter
donc on a besoin et à ce moment-là on
peut mettre des petits groupes en place
alors les groupes de besoin ça veut dire
que ça bouge ça veut dire que un un
élève va avoir un besoin sur les
fractions maématique mais il va pas
avoir de besoin sur la gramère par
exemple donc on va pouvoir mettre en
place et les groupes vont changer ça va
pas être toujours les mêmes qui vont
être ensemble à ce momentl mais est-ce
qu'on cocoune pas un peu trop les élèves
c'est ce que j'entends je le dis avec
mes mot à moi quand on dittisation
c'est donné d'empathie quand gabrielal
parle d'harcèlement et d'empathie et de
dire que le climat scolaire est
important et qu'il faut écouter les
élèves il faut avoir de l'empathie et à
un moment donné dire qu'on mais il y a
des différences de niveau c'est normal
oui c'est normal et heureusement qu'il y
en a parce que forcément les élèves ils
vont interagir entre eux moi je dis pas
qu'il faut pas changer les pratiques
bien évidemment qu'il faut les changer
et il faut donner les moyens aux
enseignants de le faire la question des
moyens on y reviendra c'est évidemment
très important par exemple il en a pas
parlé mais c'est un élément un élé
important il en a parlé mais peut-être
avec un double langage on y reviendra
tout à l'heure alors pour justifier ces
ces réformes Gabriel Atal il s'appuie
sur ce dernier classement PISA programme
internationonal pour le suivi des acquis
des élèves c'est il a été publié en en
milieu de matinée il est organisé par
l'OCDE et le niveau général il baisse un
peu
partout l'évaluation de 2022 est marqué
par une chute inédite des performances
dans l'ensemble de
l'OCDE par rapport à 2018 les
performances moyenne ont baissé de 10
points en
lecture et de près de 15 points en
mathématiqu ce qui équivaut à une
demiannée de progrès en lecture et 3/4
d'une année en
mathématique et j'accueille Tam tranui
pour développer détailler ce rapport
PISA bonsoir Tam avant de zoomer sur les
résultats français c'est quoi de quoi on
parle oui l'enquête PISA c'est une
enquête qui sonde tous les 3 ans les
performances des élèves dans trois
domaines la compréhension de l'écrit les
sciences et les mathématiques les scruté
par les gouvernements on a bien vu
aujourd'hui il l'utilise comme référence
pour infléchir leur politique éducative
et l'étude donc qui a été rendue
publique aujourd'hui elle a été menée en
2022 elle metait l'accent en particulier
sur les mathématiques et elle montre
vous l'avez dit une baisse générale de
15 points en math ce qui est un triste
record jusqu'ici les écarts entre deux
cycles d'enquête n'avaient jamais excédé
quatre points mais le covid est passé
par là et puis si on regarde la France
c'est niveau général hein et maintenant
le niveau français ex le niveau français
bah vous voyez - 21 points on se console
pas pour autant le score est qualifié
par PISA de baisse historique du niveau
des élèves alors que le score en ma
mathématique en France était resté
stable entre 2006 et 2000 2018 la baisse
du niveau en M des élèves français se
couple aussi à une augmentation du
nombre d'élèves en difficulté on est à
29 % d'élèves en difficulté et une
baisse du nombre d'élèves plus
performants qui sont seulement 7 % des
élèves de l'enquête est-ce que pour
autant la France reste dans la moyenne
de de l'OCDE une splendide moyenne
Thomas regardez ce graphique qui
concerne les performances en
mathématique des pays de l'OCDE le voici
sur le podium de tête on retrouve les
habituels Singapour Japon Corée du Sud
et globalement beaucoup de pays
asiatiques la France situe au milieu
vous le voyez juste devant il y a
l'Allemagne juste derrière il y a
l'Espagne le score de la France il est
deux points au-dessus de la moyenne de
l'OCDE et puis en fin de classement vous
trouvez le Mexique le Costa Rica ou
encore la Colombie alors je le disais
tout à l'heure l'épidémie de covid
explique la baisse de niveau général
qu'on a observé dans l'ensemble des pays
d'ailleurs au passage noter que l'étude
montre qu'il n'y a pas de lien entre la
durée de fermeture des écoles pendant le
covid et les résultats au test puisque
d'ailleurs en France c'est bien les
écoles ont été moins fermées moins
longtemps fermées qu'ailleurs mais ce
contexte bien spécifique du covid en
tout cas il complique aussi un peu la
lecture de l'étude pour départager ce
qui relève de la pandémie et ce qui
relève de causes plus structurelles et
l'OCDE pointe quand même des des
difficultés spécifiques à la France
d'abord on l'a entendu dans le reportage
de Fabien RER il y a des problèmes de
recrutement très importants il se
retrouvve dans de nombreux pays mais ils
ont très fortement augmenté en France de
2018 à aujourd'hui ensuite sachez que
par exemple il y a un vrai problème de
disciplinaire jugé préoccupant par
l'OCDE un élève sur deux se plain du
bruit et du désordre en cours de math et
enfin le problème principal majeur reste
celui du poids des inégalités sociales
sur les résultats des élèves parce que
si vous prenez les élèves de Seconde
général et de secondes technologique
leur niveau est proche de celui des pays
européens les plus performants comme
l'Estonie en revanche si vous prenez les
élèves de Seconde professionnelle vous
êtes plus proche des résultats du
Mexique donc tout en bas du classement
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que la
situation n'empire pas la mauvaise c'est
qu'elle ne s'améliore pas non plus merci
beaucoup Tam Trani pour tous ces ces
détails on va revenir sur les les
difficultés de recrutement parce que
c'est évidemment une question centrale
mais quand même cédrical je voudrais
vous entendre sur ce constat autour des
inégalités
sociales le fait que finalement non
seulement notre école n'arrive pas à les
redmir mais peut-être les creuse mais
mais c'est c'est ça je pense le
principal enseignement c'est que l'école
ne joue plus son rôle de
correction et que c'est finalement le le
statut social et la et et la
configuration de la famille qui reste
encore le le critère le le plus
déterminant et donc je pense qu'on peut
considérer que c'est un échec de l'école
euh et dans dans sa dans sa forme
actuelle c'est pour ça que ça ça nous
oblige quand même à à nous remettre en
question sur nos méthodes sur la manière
de faire car il y a une phrase qui dit
c'est le plus important c'est pas la
chute c'est l'atterrissage mais là on
voit qu'on est en pleine chute quand
même au-delà du résultat du score
relatif par rapport aux uns aux autres
on voit que de d'année en année le les
résultats se dégradent il y a des
constats qui sont quand même alarmants
quand on voit ce qui est dit dans les
cours de mathématiqu le le le problème
lié au bruit ou à la discipline mais
c'est pas que dans le mathématiqu c'est
dans tous les cours quand on on va dans
certaines salles de classes aujourd'hui
euh on a même aménagé les salles de
classe pour que les élèves puissent se
lever pendant le cours s'ils ont besoin
de bouger et cetera parce que euh ce
serait le faire leur faire violence que
de leur demander de de rester assis et
d'écouter le l'enseignant ou de
travailler à leur place je pense que on
accompagne une dégradation euh et plutôt
que de la corriger et je ne vois pas
trop aujourd'hui euh comment on va on
revient en on va on va revenir en
arrière et remonter dans le classement
si on continue euh comme on fonctionne
aujourd'hui Sophie Card vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure et puis je me
souviens d'une d'un débat qu'on avait
fait autour de la personnalité de de
garbatal où vous aviez dit il s'attaque
au clergé de l'éducation nationale euh
est-ce que vous pouvez détailler euh
c'est qui ce clerger de l'éducation
nationale et quel poids il a dans ces
voilà mauvais résultats même si on n'est
pas les seuls même si le niveau général
de euh des des élèves de l'OCDE est en
train de baisser oui ah alors le clergé
de l'éducation nationale c'est très
simple c'est une euh comment diraitge
euh c'est toute une catégorie que que je
qualifieraiis de hiérarchie
intermédiaire et quelquefois
d'hiérarchie supérieure euh qui sont
attachés à un certain nombre de dogmes
comme tout clerger qui se respecte euh
et parmi ces dogmes il y a effectivement
celui de la non stigmatisation enfin
tout le monde c'est hallucinant parce
que euh enfin je veux dire à part euh
quelqu ça dit que personne n'est pour
stigmatiser les élèves la question n'est
pas là la question est quelle est la
meilleure manière de ne pas stigmatiser
les élèves de faire progresser le plus
grand nombre et notamment de que l'école
soit ce qui devrait effectivement être
un de ses rôles de sinon euh totalement
écrasé du moins de gommer les inégalités
or qu'est-ce qu'on constate moi c'est ce
que j'ai constaté quand j'ai fait
plusieurs livres sur l'éducation
nationale en enquêtant qu'est-ce que
j'ai constaté et PU et ça malheure
heureusement je veux dire je je suis pas
contente de continuer à avoir raison
croyez-moi mais on constate que bah les
inégalités augmentent alors pourquoi les
inégalités augmentent euh bah c'est
quand même à se demander en tout cas ça
veut dire que les que les dogmes qui
sont appliqué depuis une trentaine
d'années ne fonctionne pas sinon euh les
inégalités auraient diminué or ils ont
été forgé poliis pour justement
euh corriger les inégalités qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire bah moins
d'exigence moins d'attention porté à la
transmission des savoirs pur et dur un
peu un peu à l'ancienne hein à la papa
on va dire et plus de comment dirais-je
de coconstruction alors ça s'est appelé
de différentes manières sous le règne de
Najet Valot belcassem on avait atteint
des sortes de sommets avec effectivement
des enseignements au collège
interdisciplinaires qui en gros enfin
étaient des heures perdues pour la
transmission des savoirs c'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez essayer de croiser
l'éducation physique et le français ça
peut être très sympa dans un dans un
cadre où par ailleurs les acquis
fondamentaux sont là mais fondamentx si
sont pas là je veux dire ça me paraît
être un petit peu du euh du du vernis
inutile voire toxique Guilen David
peut-être votre votre réponse à ce à ce
clerger là à son à son poids et
peut-être ses erreurs he si je reprends
les arguments de de Sophie cagard et et
et et votre avis sur cette cette spirale
là de de de baisse régulière de de
niveau des collégiens français il y a
une certitude c'est qu'il y a un fossé
enfin c'est même plus un fossé entre le
ministère et le terrain le terrain c'est
les professeurs des écoles qui sont dans
leur classe au quotidien et qui gèent
leur classe qui gère les parents
d'élèves qui gèent les relations avec
les élus et il y a un tel fossé qu' a il
y a plus de compréhension entre ces deux
mondes et ça c'est et à chaque fois
qu'on interroge les les enseignants il y
a une étude de de Éric de Barbieux sur
le climat scolaire qu' a fait
dernièrement qui dit que plus aucun
enseignant n'a confiance dans la
hiérarchie la hiérarchie intermédiaire
mais aussi la hiérarchie plus haute du
ministère mais c'est quoi c'est moi
j'entends pardon le terme de pédagogisme
c'est une espèce de de de de vision
intellectuelle de l'école c'est ça ce
qu' je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit clair
on pratique un métier notre métier c'est
professeur des école en tout cas en
voilà je suis enseignante j'ai fait
voilà j'ai passé des j'ai fait mes
études pour faire ça je suis je
considère que je suis experte dans mon
métier bon c'est enfin comme vous vous
êtes expert dans votre métier parce que
c'est votre métier voilà c'est ça vous
essayez moi aussi j'essaie modestement
mais on a toujours et toute façon quand
on interroge la population sur
l'éducation tout le monde a un avis sur
l'éducation
t parélèv par d'élèves et élèves donc on
se réfère à son propre vécu donc chacun
a un avis et de fait on voit bien qu' a
il y a des et c'est pareil pour le
ministre c'est-à-dire que lui-même a ses
ses propres savoir s propr croyance sur
l'éducation et va les reporter mais moi
ce que je ce que je constate c'est qu'on
fait de moins en moins confiance à
l'expertise même des
je vais mettre les pieds dans le plat
est-ce que vous mettez les syndicats
dans le pédagogisme dans le clerger des
pas tous tous pas tous enfin il y a des
Sicat qui sont qui baignent
dedans totalement et il y en a d'autres
qui qui se réfèrent à la à la
transmission des savoirs et ça n'est
même pas corrélé je dirais à une
étiquette politique et syndicale il y a
des syndicat de gauche qui milite pour
la transmission des savoirs et pour la
préservation de tout cela donc non avoir
une une le enfin de mon point de vue
toutes les enquêtes que j'ai pu mener
là-dessus il y a pas de corrélation
directe qui soit un clivage politique ou
un clivage euh syndical ouais allez-y
mais quand on est enseignant on milite
tous pour la transmission des savoirs
c'est notre métier de transmettre des
savoirs on est là pour éleverl mais pas
au niveau d'une certaine bule mais moi
j'ai vu j'ai vu arriver comme parents
d'élèves des manuels où je me disais
comment on va transmettre le savoir avec
ces manuels là péag d'acordvec vous sur
la question des manuel mais c'est
Gabriel àal qui REM en jeu
l'emmanueléit voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'à un moment donné on est tous
là quand on est enseignant on est là
pour faire progresser nos élèves c'est
notre but moi j'aiété très longtemps
enseignante en CP mon objectif de
l'année c'était quand même que mes
élèves apprennent à lire j'avais pas
d'autres objectif dans ce que j'entends
ce que vous dites il a cette idée de
retour aux fondamentaux alors c'est un
peu une tarte à la crème mais ça veut
quand même dire quelque chose aussi
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Cédric
est-ce que parce que peut-être que
beaucoup de ministres ont employer ces
term là depuis que Emmanuel Macron est
est président de la République mais
est-ce que c'est quand même la base mais
mais oui c'est la base moi je suis
effondré quand je vois un ministre qui
et celui-ci comme les précédents qui dit
mais vous vous rendez compte l'objectif
c'est d'apprendre c'est de savoir lire
et écrire quand on rentre en 6e mais
c'est mais c'est quand on sort de CP
qu'on doit savoir lire et écrire CE1 les
programmes c'est CE1 la lecture mais
déjà c'est c'est déjà un manque
d'ambition c'est mais non les pays
nordiques c'est 7 ans là je je lecture
en tout cas la 6e c'est un peu tard on
est mais oui et et enfin comment
voulez-vous qu'un élève qui va passer 3
ans sans savoir lire et écrire en école
primaire euh puisse suivre une scolarité
normale puisse ne pas s'enfoncer dans
des comportements qui qui aideront pas
forcément les autres à suivre non plus
et comment voulez-vous je je repose la
question de l'évaluation aussi tout à
l'heure qu'on s'en aperçoit finalement
que au bout de de ou 3 ans on a
l'impression qu'on découvre un en CM2 ah
mais il sait pas lire mais alors mais il
a fait quoi pendant 3 ans dans la classe
on l'a laissé dans dans un coin de la
classe sans s'en apercevoir je je pense
pas que la plupart des enseignants la
plupart s'en aperçoivent mais mais on a
quand même une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui de de laisser aller en
disant bah toute façon ça passera là
Gabriel Atal a demandé au justement au
professeur des écoles je pense que vous
avez reçu le message aussi en français
de
osser le curseur et en métaméique par
exemple he fraction et nombre décimau ce
sera à partir du CE1 et alors donc voilà
plusambition vous dites l'AMB non ça
c'est une question de méthode je pense
que un moment donné là aussi c'est le
problème du ministre il faut qu'il fasse
son boulot et pas celui des autres il
est pas enseignant il est pas chef
d'établissement c'est pas lui de de
fixer non plus la méthode je crois aussi
à la liberté pédagogique vous avez
raison moi je critique les enseignants
quand ils prennent pour le ministre ou
qui conteste la décion du ministre mais
faut pas non plus que le ministre se
prenne pour les enseignants et c'est pas
parce qu'on va mettre la décimale à ce
momentl ou un autre que que qu'on va
régler le problème des mathématiques
c'est c'est c'est pas vrai déjà
concentrons-nous sur le transmission des
savoirs apprenonsleur à lire et à écrire
et vérifions qu'ils sachent le faire et
mettons les moyens quand ils sachent pas
le faire pour qu'il puissent le faire et
pas en 6e et pas mais mais dès le CP le
CE1 pour qu'il puissent suivre une
scolarité normale but mais enfin moi
j'ai j'ai euh quand même dans dans les
dans les prof parmi les professeurs des
écoles que j'ai interrogé notamment ceux
qui sont ce qui enseignent en en CM2 euh
donc l'année d'avant le passage en 6e
j'ai eu des des témoignages selon
lesquels effectivement des élèves qui
étaient en détresse en terme de de de de
de maîtrise de la lecture de l'écriture
éventuellement des bases mathématiques
euh et que c'est et que ces professeurs
voulaient faire redoubler encore une
fois pas par sadisme mais pas pour ne
pas les envoyer à l'abattoir au collège
se sont vu alors effectivement il y a le
consumérisme parental qui est un vrai
sujet c'est-à-dire non non mon enfant ne
redoublera pas et là moi je trouve que
l'idée que la que la dernière décision
viienne au professeur est parfaitement
normal mais il y avait aussi et j'en
reviens là euh la la la la le poids de
de de de de l'Académie en fait de
l'administration qui qui descendait
directement du ministère de la rue de
Grenel et qui expliquait à ses
professeurs des écoles que non on ne
faisait pas redoubler alors enfin la
moindre empathie à l'égard de ces
élèvesl c'est c'était de dire mais enfin
je ne veux pas les les envoyer dans
enfin dans cet étatl si j'ose dire en 6e
et une finé moi ce que ce que ce que ce
qui me paraît terrible c'est que il y
avait une sorte d'alliance euh j'allais
dire presque doctrinale entre d'une part
euh un management à l'économie
c'est-à-dire que ne pas faire redoubler
des élèves et ben ça coûte moins cher je
suis désolé mais il y a cette espèce de
cette espèce de sous-jacent gestionnaire
qui est toujours là et d'autre part
effectivement l'idée qu'il fallait pas
stigmatiser et derrière l'idée de non
stigmatisation bah finalement on a aussi
fait des économies sur le dos des élèves
les plus faible ou alors justement la
question du redoublement je vous propose
on va on va en débattre je vous propose
de d'écouter C c'est peut-être un
changement de doctrine appelons ça comme
ça proposé par
Gabriel les professeurs auront désormais
le dernier mot en matière de
redoublement je prendrai un décret au
début de l'année 2024 pour modifier le
code de l'éducation en ce sens en
tranchant ce débat
je veux lutter contre l'échec forcé
auquel peuvent être condamnés des élèves
que l'on veut faire passer à tout prix
en classe supérieure pour ces élèves
deux choix s'offriront au professeurs en
fin d'année un passage sous conditions
avec du tutorat des stages de réussite
durant le leurs vacances scolaires je
rappelle que nous avons d'ors et déjà
40000 enseignants volontaires qui font
des stages de réussite pendant les
vacances et que nous doublons désormais
leur rémunération pour ces stages de
réussite dans le cadre du Pacte
enseignant autre possibilité le
redoublement en cas de grandes
difficulté car je le dis de manière très
claire il vaut mieux réussir son
primaire en 6 ans que l'échouer en
5 guiden David est-ce que c'était du un
tabou le redoublement ou alors à
l'inverse une doctrine pas de
redoublement dans l'éducation
nationale'éta ni un tabou ni une
doctrine c'était une décision qui a été
prise suite aux enquêtes qui ont été
menées dans les années 2000 et dans les
années 2015 notamment avec une grande
enquête du knesco notamment à
l'international qui qui a montré sur des
Cortes très importantes he c'est c'est
très bien renseigné la question du
redomblement que si c'était efficace
juste après c'est-à-dire l'année d'après
sur le long terme ça a des effets
néfastes sur la scolar la scolarité de
de l'élève donc on a conclu et
d'ailleurs c'est une des recommandations
de PISA PISA dans ses recommandations
aujourd'hui dit il faut limiter le
redoublement euh et tous les pays
nordiques notamment qui qui réussissent
bien et qui réussissent les mieux de
l'OCDE ne font pas redoubler les élèves
alors pourquoi comment on fait si on les
fait par redoubler parce qu'
effffectivement on voit bien c'est une
croyance sur les redoublement on peut se
dire bah il faut laisser le prendre le
temps et on va le le
l'aider à reprendre les base l'année
d'après il faut prévenir ça c'est-à-dire
que c'est bien avant qu'il faut prévenir
évidemment qu'il faut pas attendre la
fin du CM2 évidemment c'est une évidence
mais sauf que quand on a mais c'est ce
qu'on fait mais parce que qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'on a comme moyen dans nos
classes pour le
faire quel moyen quand on a 29 élèves
par par classe qu'on a des élèves qu'on
accue de plus en plus je vous rappelle
queon a une loi et c'est normal sur
l'inclusion qui doit nous permettre
d'inclure tous les élèves à trou avec
des troubles et et et porteur de
handicap qui ont parfois qui sont des
ces élèves à besoins éducatifs
particuliers qui qui avant ne relevaient
pas de l'école qui relèv bien évidemment
de l'école maintenant et il faut les
inclure mais on n' pas les moyens de les
inclure donc on a des élèves sur
lesquels on va concentrer des efforts et
on pourra pas s'occuper des autres oui
mais pour autantut pas satisfaire ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure de laisser
rentrer en
6eè élève qui maîtrise pas on aura pas
plus oui parce qu'il faut il faut
changer il faut changer la politique
éducative mais c'est pas en supprimant
1700 postes à la rentrée prochaine dans
le premier degré on va encore fermer des
classes et donc effectivement alors je
sais pas si on fait redoubler
massivement je sais pas comment on va
faire pour ces élèvesl parce qu'ils vont
ils vont ils vont sent assés dans les
classes mais en tout cas on voit bien
que là aussi on n pas prévenu on avait
des réseaux d'aide des enseignants
spécialisés dans la grande difficulté
scolaire il passent une certification
pour être spécialisé ils ont un une
capacité à intervenir sur ces élèves là
ils ont été massivement supprimé ces
postes là donc on se retrouve et je vous
le dis seul en formation initiale avec
moins de formation c'est aussi ça le
problème c'est qu'on a moins de
formation maintenant quand on devient
enseignant c'est est-ce que c'est une
question ou seulement une question de
moyen de de d'effectif non non ça peut
pas être ça et et même si le
redoublement n'est pas forcément la
solution redoubler refaire refaire faire
la même chose à un élève qu' l'a pas
compris la première fois si c'est pas
accompagné de mesure ça marche pas
forcément systématiquement effectivement
il y avait des études qui montraient que
c'était pas forcément la panacé euh
néanmoins je pense qu' a il y a un le
redoublement il faut essayer de l'éviter
mais donc on doit pouvoir l'éviter par
des mesures peut-être des stages d'été
moi je je j'aime bien l'idée de de dire
qu' on a des des mesures qui pevent être
complémentaires au passage mais qui
au-delà de l'été ça peut même être un
contrat avec un accompagnement sur
l'année suivante et en disant par contre
il y a des objectifs si l'année
prochaine tu y arrives très bien sinon
tu redoubleras l'année prochaine ça
suppose des effectifs supplémentaires
mais mais peut-être mais on on a déjà
aujourd'hui on est plus à 29 par classe
he on est on est plutôt à 24 en moyenne
et et et en tout cas je pense si on veut
arriver à avoir des objectifs c'est sur
l'école primaire qu'il faut mettre ces
moyenslà mais par contre le redoublement
il peut avoir un intérêt dans dans un
certain nombre de cas et deuxièmement
c'est surtout le fait qu'on l' interdit
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme ça que
c'est interprété il y a pas de
redoublement si si si la famille n'en
veut pas c'est une mesure de prévention
aussi si parce que pour l'élève c'est
une motivation de se dire je veux passer
dans la classe suérieur le fait d'être
revenu sur sur le redoublement on a
multiplié finalement leseffet négatif de
de de laisser aller de à la fois des FAM
du une doctrine c'est ce que vous nous
dites ou une consigne oui aujourd'hui
c'est une doctrine enfin aujourd'hui il
y a pas de redoublement et et et pour
les enfants comme pour les familles la
motivation de passer dans la classe
supérieure a disparu et aujourd'hui on n
pas besoin de supprimer les quelques
motivations qui restent aux élèves pour
travailler ce qui va avec puisque là on
est sur le le passage encien c'est le le
brevet il faut avoir son brevet pour
pouvoir passer en en 6e ça ça semble du
du bon sens en tout cas c'est ce que je
veux faire en seconde pardon
effectivement le brevet c'est en fin de
3è on voit que ça fait longtemps que mes
enfants sont son sont plus au collège
brevet pour passer en seconde c'est un
peu la même idée Sophie coagard parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de ces
élèves qui réussissent pas le brevet bah
c'est les
accpagne Gabri enfin que j'ai écouté
avec attention ne m'a pas semblé
forcément très diert c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que je mets derrière
c'est-à-dire que il y a on va pas voilà
il va pas y avoir un butoir avec avec
des des des élèves qui euh euh qui parce
qu'ils n'ont pas réussi un examen bah
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils redouble
peut-être c'est c'est pire que ça parce
que Thomas il a aussi dit dans la même
conférence de presse qu'il en avait fini
avec les consignes académiques les
consignes officieuses alors ce qu'on
appelle la oui ce qu'on appelle les
corrections les corrections académiques
des notes c'est-à-dire que ah il y a pas
assez de brevet il y a pas assez de B de
on va passer à 10 et pu comme bon ce qui
un vrai ce les conction académique c'est
un vrai sujet cela dit hein parce que
enfin les témoignages de correcteurs que
j'ai
eu vous avez totalement raison c'est que
il met doublement la barre haut sans
trop expliquer ce qu'il va faire de ceux
qui passent en dessous parce que
effectivement il y a au brevet comme au
bac ce qu'on appelle les corrections
académiques alors les corrections
académiques au départ c'est de
l'harmonisation évidemment vous avez
statistiquement un paquet de copies à
corriger il est pas forcément euh
comment dirais-je équivalent à un autre
paquet de copie très bien ça c'est ça
c'est ce qu'on vous dit c'est la
présentation vitrine la vérité c'est que
depuis des années la correction
académique l'harmonisation comme on
l'appelle ça consiste juste à reéhausser
les notes pour que le la fièvre du
malade ne se voit pas sur le thermomètre
c'est exactement ça et ça franchement
j'ai des témoignages multiples qui vont
tous dans le même sens mais là qu'est-ce
que dit Gabriel Atal et et moi je suis
plutôt d'accord dans l'absolu euh le
brevet après tout réhabilitons le brevet
faisons faisant on autre chose que cette
espèce de truc de formalité dont tout le
monde se fiche absolument et après tout
que que des que des collégiens se
confronte à un examen à enjeu moi je
trouve que c'est bien euh premièrement
et deuxièmement il l'a dit comme ça
rendons le brevet plus difficile c'est
dire arrêtons d'en faire un
machinit de ceux qui le rat bien ré là
mystère et boules de gomme parce que je
n'ai pas entendu quoi que ce soit
sortant du ministère qui me donnait des
indications làdus l'objet d'une troisème
conférence de presse un autre collège
une autre bibliothèque alors justement
Laeticia elle a été soigneusement
préparée cette conférence de presse
séquence importante pour le ministre ah
oui puisque il ne s'agit pas uniquement
pour Gabriel hatal de se reposer sur ses
lauriers de star de la rentrée hein
Laier qu'il a eu dans les sondages comme
il le dit il le dit en privé j'entre
dans le dur ça c'est sa formule donc il
sait très bien que pour la première fois
peut-être depuis son arrivée rugnel il
va être confronté au monde éducatif on
en a l'exemple sur ce plateau c'est la
valeur de test pour lui d'ailleurs on
peut le le dire comment il a il a
préparé cette conférence de
presse il y avait eu déjà une une autre
conférence c'était le 5 octobre dernier
alors là le le le cadre était différent
hein à la BNF donc c'était un cadre
solennel parce qu'il il annoncé ce qu'il
allait faire en fait il a lancé ce qu'il
allait annoncé comme chantier et là
cette fois-ci on est 3 mois exactement
après la BNF il a chois le terrain pour
dire ce qu'il allait faire enfin parce
qu'il dit souvent en privé il dit
souvent je ne suis pas qu'un dieser je
suis aussi un faiseur donc là il a
choisi un collège d'arrondissement du
19e arrondissement de Paris il a dit que
ce collège pour lui était exemplaire
parce queil avait réussi à faire monter
les résultats alors que des familles
étaient quand même dans la grande
difficulté et donc pour lui c'est
possible on peut se remonter les manches
c'est ce qu'il a dit au journalistes
avant la conférence de presse c'est pour
ça qu' a choisi ce ce collège pour
illustrer un peu ce remontage de manch
on va dire h alors il reconnaît en privé
que il a a quelques résistances on va
dire il dit il nous dit j'ai trouvé la
parade euh les enseignants sont
consultés c'est ça ah oui c'est ce qu'il
a dit il dit oui c'est vrai qu'il y aura
certainement des r des résistances à mes
mesures mais là il a parlé d'abord à
l'opinion publique pendant la conférence
de presse mais aussi évidemment au corps
enseignant vous le savez vous étiez
peut-être les premiers les plus les plus
attentifs et il sait que bon quand on
lui pose cette question il sait que il
reconnaît il peut y avoir des
résistances mais sa réponse quand même
est claire il dit je suis confiant
pourquoi Thomas parce que selon lui
depuis le 5 octobre les enseignants tous
les enseignants ont été consultés soit
oralement soit par écrit et il a donné
un chiffre il a dit que 230000
enseignants ont répondu alors je ne sais
pas si c'est votre cas ont répondu à un
questionnaire en ligne ouais et dans ces
230000 80 % tu pouv répondre était
favorable nous débr tout à l'heure et
donc çaagasse un peu des questions qu'on
lui pose sur ce sur ce thème là oui
parce qu'il dit je ne suis pas du tout
un ministre horsol je suis sur le
terrain tous les jours je suis en
discussion continue alors ça vous pouvez
peut-être le confirmer ou l'infirmeré
mais avec les organisations syndicales
il dit je leur parle de façon quasi
quotidienne je vais à la rencontre des
enseignants je suis sur le terrain donc
il est confiant pour voilà pour que
leamp enseignant le SU
est-ce que c'est une façon de se
rassurer aussi je pense en tout cas
c'est vrai que Gabriel hatal avance à
pas de velours parce que il sait que en
touchant à des totems comme le bac le
prevet le redoublement les notes il peut
il s'expose à la vindicte du monde
éducatif et on a vu que par le passé le
monde de l'éducation nationale peut
faire un peu l'appuie et le BE temp de
la vie d'un ministre en tout cas rue de
Grenelle donc on va voir si ces réformes
de fond vont comment va tourner le monde
enseignant est-ce qu'il sera pour ou
contre Gabriel Atal et ce sera même un
très bon indicateur pour sa durée de vie
Rud Grenel mais plus pour sa popularité
d'hom politique plus généralement pour
sa popularité alors ce questionnaire
tiens je veux bien vous entendre gu
David là-dessus c'était c'était quoi et
ce chiffre dont don n parle Gabriel 80 %
des professeurs favorables aux mesures
qu'il a annoncé alors 80 % favorable aux
mesures non c'est dire qu' y a il y a
230000 alors je vais pas dire
enseignants qui ont répondu puisque on a
reçu un lien pour une consultation un
lien qui était public donc voilà qui
était public et sur lequel on pouvait
répondre le nombre de fois qu'on voulait
je vais vous avouer quelques chose j'ai
répondu cinq fois j'ai pu répondre cinq
fois et ou donc c'était quelque chose
qui n'était absolument pas scientifique
donc il y a énormément de doublon et
c'est un lien qui a qui qui était publ
donc je connais des gens qui n'étaient
pas enseignants VO même des journalistes
qui ont répondu aussi des des des
personn des personnes politiques qui
m'ont dit aussi avoir répondu donc il y
a il y avait la possibilité de rép
raison ils ont hacké ce questionnaire
alors il était pas il était il était
c'était c'est un lien si vous voulez moi
je enfin n'importe qui le partageait on
pouvait répondre c'était pas quelque
chose de protégé c'était pas une enquête
scientifique comme vous avez à certain
moment où d'ailleurs qu'on peut avoir où
on est obligé de on pourrait
s'identifier parce qu'on a des numéros
pour s'identifier on pourrait
s'identifier recevoir un mail de
confirmation en disant confirme a ça n'a
pas été le donc n'était pas une
consultation scientifique c'était une
consultation ça durit 3 minutes en gros
pour répondre c'est pas forcément
quelque chose qui qui est vraiment vous
dites que le dialogue existe pas
vraiment non le dialogue n'existe pas et
je vous le dis effectivement il dit qu'
qu'il consulte les organisation
syndicale lui personnellement il est en
dialogue continu ce sont les qu' a
utilisé il a une conseillère sociale
qui discute avec les organisations
syndicales mais lui personnellement moi
depuis enfin je suis syndicat
majoritaire dans le 1emier degré euh en
réunion bilatérale avec lui je n'ai eu
qu'un rendez-vous depuis le mois d'août
donc on ne l'a on le voit dans certaines
réunions il reste 10 minutes il nous
écoute 10 minutes il repart euh on l'a
vu je je le dis quand même au moment des
événements d'aras on l'a vu là il a pris
le temps de discuter avec les
organisations syndicales et là pour le
coup on a été entendu écoué et il a pris
ce temps-là ça on ne peut pas le lui
reprocher mais sur les les sujets aussi
forts que ce sujet des ch des savoirsce
qui passe pas avec Gabriel Atal déjà et
je pense que c'est c'est c'est un c'est
un homme politique qui a de l'ambition
mais qui travaille beaucoup la
communication et on le savait quand il
est arrivé au au sein de ministère vous
l'avez dit il y a eu la BNF il y a ici
il travaille beaucoup la communication
chaque sortie de Gabriel l tal est un
moment de communication je sais pas si
vous avez vu sur les réseaux sociaux il
a investi les réseaux sociaux WhatsApp
TikTok Instagram tous les réseaux
sociaux tous les ministres ne font pas
ou peut aussi dire que c'est un ministre
de son époque mais bon ça c'est mais je
je voudrais c'est intéressant parce que
tout à l'heure vous nous parliez de
voilà de de de de
ces moi je parle de pédagogie s de ce
clerger de l'éducation nationale qui
peut oui ou non avoir l'impôt d'un
ministre bien sûr mais c'est déjà arrivé
enfin bah je je pense notamment à parce
qu'il y a toujours la question j'ai
enfin de beaucoup mais j'ai un souvenir
partic enfin de témoignages
particulièrement cuisant euh ça déjà un
certain temps c'était Gilles deobien et
Gilles deobien c'était un ministre qui
était comme il m'avait dit moi j'ai pas
compris quand on m'a appelé pour être
ministre parce que je suis pas du sérail
je n'ai pas des des diplômes à accrocher
magnifique à accrocher au mur de mon
bureau et d'ailleurs disait-il très
sympathiquement et j'étais très mauvais
élève bref et et donc éit pas prédestiné
à devenir ministducation nationale on
non non mais surtout c'est parce que ça
ça amène à autre chose c'estd est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux choisir un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui sort du qui
sort de la marmite ou au contraire qui
est parfaite outsider alors on voit bien
que si on ge Claude Allègre ou
Jean-Michel Blanquer ça porte pas
forcément chance de sortir de la marmite
donc Gabriel àal moi je pense que c'est
plutôt une chance qu'il ne soit pas du
sers non pour pour lui pour pour ses
chances de de durer de durer c'est en
gros de résister à cette à cette
suradministration parce queil y a on
manque de prof mais on manque pas de
fonctionnaire à l'éducation nationale ça
je peux vous l'assurer bref toujours
est-il que Gilles de Robien veut de
manière un peu c'est vrai peut-être
simpliste aux yeux de ce de ce clerger
sur sur informé et sur éduquer veut dit
bah écoutez moi je suis désolée j'ai
regardé les manuels d'apprentissage de
la lecture alors il y en a plein moi je
suis désolé je peux la méthode globale
j'y comprends rien alors la office enfin
tout le le monde est auusqué de Gen mais
plus personne ne la pratique et puis en
fait quand même si il y avait des gens
qui la pratiquaient et cetera et donc il
il pont une circulaire làdessus et enfin
il a été plus que enfin ça a été
horrible c'est-à-dire queil y avait des
il y avait des des inspecteur d'académie
qui allit sur les plateaux pour se
moquer de lui de la méthode à Roro et
cetera on l'a fait passer pour une sorte
d'ilétré qui comprenait rien avec un
mépris absolument enfin que moi j'ai
trouvé extrêmement choquant et euh et
donc effectivement est-ce que le est-ce
que voilà est-ce que le clerger peut
avoir la peau d'un ministre pour moi la
réponse est oui s fois oui bon allez on
termine là-dessus merci beaucoup je suis
désolé le débat est terminé un tout
petit mot très rapide alors vraiment 30
secondes non non mais j'étais conseillé
de chilorbi j'ai j'ai vécu les choses un
peu différemment mais euh je je pense
que c'est la fin des 100 jours pour
Gabriel Atal il montre qu'il a certain
talent d'homme politique mais le
ministère d' l'éducation nationale n'est
pas un ministère comme les autres et je
pense qu'il va le comprendre parce que
je pense qu'il y a il y a une intention
mais sur la méthode il est pas encore
tout à fait prêt je on pourra refaire
des débats pour faire son bilan dans
dans quelques dans quelques mois merci à
tous d'avoir participé à à ce sens
public et à bientôt sur public scénage
je rappelle le titre de votre livre
Sophie coagard la tyrannie de la
médiocrité pourquoi il faut sauver le
mérite publié aux éditions de
l'Observatoire